ich bin heute zusammen mit einem
Kollegen aus dem verrücktesten
Deutschland geflohen indem wir einfach
den günstigsten Flug gebucht haben das
ganze kann man prima mit Skyscanner
machen das ist eine App oder eine
Website gibt einfach alle Orte ein und
zack bei uns was Lanzarote 59 € pro
Person und wir saßen schon im Flieger
und aufgings in die Sonne mit ganz
vielen deutschen Rentnern zusammen saßen
wir im Flugzeug Boom 24 Grad auf
Lanzarote wir sind angekommen super
entspannt ja ich klicke gerade unter der
Bettdecke während ich für euch das Audio
aufnehme aber hier saßen noch ein Taxi
schönen Palmen auch direkt am Meer und
dann ging es erstmal in die Unterkunft
die haben wir auch billig geschossen
hier haben wir aber alles was man
brauchen bettenart schön viel Platz und
ja das bin ich hallo dann ging es zum
Beach wunderbar alles voll mit deutschen
aber ist ja kein Problem ein Bierchen
muss auch immer sein kaltes Bier und ja
hinter mir seht ihr noch mal das Meer
dann saß beim Restaurant und jetzt
gleich gehen wir noch in die Stadt geil
und morgen fliegen wir weiter